foreign
is one of the emerging programming
languages according to the most recent
figures python is the most used coding
language for about 80 percent of
Developers the syntax of this high-level
programming language is simple to
understand
pythons large Library System makes it a
best choice for data science machine
learning and artificial intelligence
projects so hello Learners welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel and today
we have come up with some amazing python
projects that will help you to improve
your python skills we will create an MP3
player and video player using python but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel
like the tutorial and hit the Bell icon
to never miss an update
we will create a MP3 player using Python
and before starting first we should have
a look on what we would create
for that we will move to our code
simply run this
you can see that the take into window
has appeared and this is a media player
we have named it simply music player we
have the GIF that would be running
continuously
and we have the browse music pattern
which will direct you to the any folder
you want to open that have the MP3
player files
I have selected this folder it has four
files
and will play Hey there
you just click on that and click on the
play button
music
now just click on the post button
so this is our MP3 player
so before starting the coding
I have a simple question for you guys
so moving to that
so the question is who wrote the poem
Zen of python
and your options are
diminishly
Tim Peters
where do I do some
or Kevin Goldsmith
you could see the poem here also you can
easily get this poem you just have to
write import this you know interpreter
and just press enter you won't get the
poem
so please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the print comment
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section
so moving to a code
first we will create a folder
and name it as
create
MP3 player
using python
and inside
will open the command prompt
and write the command code space
so appeared and press enter
this will open up the editor that is
Visual Studio code
if you want you can use any editor you
have hands on animator you can use
anyone
and here we will create a file and
name it as player.py only
and we would require music also
for that and some gifs and some images
for our buttons you can easily
get those images from any
three images website or you can just get
them draw in the paint or photoshop them
you can
arrange them from anywhere
so we have our picks in this folder
so we'll copy all these and we have the
music folder
it has four files and this is the
copyright free music so we can play on
YouTube
we will
is this enough fold only
that is create MP3 player using python
yeah
going back to our Visual Studio code
the first thing is we should install the
python packages before starting our
coding
so we would require the take into
package it is already installed as you
install the python if you want to
install it again just
go to a terminal
and write the command with install
TK
as you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied so you I don't have to
install it again
you can install it just writing the
command and press enter
and the next we have to install is the
pi game to import the mixer class
sorry the command would be
pip install Pi game
and press enter
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied I have already
installed the pi game module you just
have to write the command and press
enter you will get them installed very
easily in the next module we need is
time
so you can install the date time module
or the time module
it's your wish
so we have
to write the command
web install date time
so it was not installed
on my system
it has been installed and
it doesn't have some
classes in the module it has installed
them and it says the requirement is
already satisfied for other modules okay
so now
and the last is OS module
install the
this window is not going so we will just
go to the terminal
just get a terminal
and write the command here yep
install
OS
o s and press enter
so it will install the OS module for you
it is doing for me right now
foreign
module to create the GUI and tick enter
is a python module that is used to
develop graphical user interface and as
I told you there's no need to install it
it is the part of the standard python
Library so it would be installed as you
installed python on your system
so it's downloading till then
we'll just import our packages
first we'll import
time and that we will use an
to get the GIF setup in our GUI
so we'll import the time and from tick
into
all the classes
and
we will import the field dialog
and from PI game we'll import the mixer
class to get a buttons functioning to
make our mp3 music video music
like MP3 file to start playing to pause
it and to resume it again
so for that I'll write the command
from PI game
import mixer
it's still downloading
till then we'll import the OS also
it will get it
download it and install for us
so first we will create the tick enter
video window
for that we'll write the simple command
root
equal to
t k
and circular brackets and
hit the command root Dot
main Loop
and if we save it and run it
no sorry it was downloading
[Music]
um
just pause the downloading okay we'll
see it again so you can see that the TK
enter window has appeared on the screen
it's the output
it's a simple take into video now we
will add functions to it we will add
size to it we will add background color
and we'll do other functionings to that
so tick enter provides many methods and
one of them is geometry method
and it is used to set the dimensions of
the take enter window as you have seen
so we will just position the main window
on the user's desktop we will use the
command root dot geometry for that
set the size as 485
cross
that is X only
and for y-axis it would be 700
and now
you would get it
290 points shifted from x-axis
and
10 points shifted from y-axis
we have to put them in inverted commas
we will save the file and run it again
you can see that the take into window
has changed its geometry and it has set
the x-axis as 485 and Y X is at 700 and
when it appeared it was
290
and see what dimension it uses it was
290 points apart from the x-axis and 70
sorry 10 points apart from y-axis yeah
290 and 10.
so now we'll give the title to this
window
for that we will write the command
through do title
and just write that item
do you want to give it you can give it
anyway
so we will name it as simply music
player
and now we'll use the configure function
so take into configure function it is
used on any widget to change settings
that you may have applied earlier or
haven't applied yet
so for that we'll write the command
root dot configure
and we will set the background color
so
right
background
equal to an inverted commas we'll write
the hexa code
for this color
we are setting the gray color
for a background we'll save it
and run the file so you can see the
output
so we have set the simply music player
as the root title for taking top window
and we have configured background color
right screen
so moving on
now we will use the resizable method it
is used to allow tick enter root window
to change its size according to the
user's need
as well as it will prohibit like it will
not allow you to change the size of the
window
the window you just sew on the screen
that was a take enter window so we will
use the resizable function and we will
prohibit will not allow anyone to change
its dimensions
so for that we will write the command
root dot resizable
volts comma
forwards so in this sizeable method user
can pass either positive integer or true
to make them into resizable to make
window non-recizable user can just pass
zero or false we have passed faults so
our window won't be resizable
and save this file and run it again and
see now we can't resize it
so first I will command this command and
save it and run it for you guys
you can see that
you can resize it now but after we write
this command
no one is allowed to resize The Tick
enter window
we'll save this
and run it you can see
now no one is allowed to resize this
window you won't get any option
so now
moving on as you have
seen the previous dimensions and the
demonstration of the simply music player
will create
as same as that only
so we will place the GIF here a label
here and place the buttons on that and
beneath that we will just create a label
and browse all the files there
foreign
for that we'll write the command
first we'll create a
variable and name it as lower frame and
a frame is a rectangular region on the
screen
it can be used as a foundation class to
implement complex widgets it is used to
organize a group of widgets so we'll be
creating a frame and we'll Place
different buttons on that that would be
the play button post button and the stop
button and the volume
that is just the image
we'll place the volume image there
so lower frame equal to
we will write frame to get a frame
and inside we will pass root
and get a background color as white
that will write the hexagon
Ash and the hexa code for white color is
FFF and that is six times you can go and
search on the web about the hexagotes
like which color is associated with
which hexa code or you can just write
the simple name of the colors you can
get your background set as well that
also
and here we'll set the width for our
frame
so width will set as 485 only it should
cover the whole window
in X dimensions
and for height we will set it as 180.
we'll create the same simply multiplayer
as I have shown in new as I have shown
the demonstration earlier
so we have set the height as 180
so
now
we will use the Place method that allows
you to explicitly set the position and
size of a window or anything like we are
just creating a frame so it would use to
position and size of the frame
it would be either in absolute terms or
relative
to another window so for that
we will write the command
first
you will get the frame
that is stored in the lower underscore
frame
variable
and use the place function
to place it in a ticket window
and write the dimensions for that we
would start from x equal to 0
and paste it at y equal to
400.
now we'll save the file
and run it
okay we have one ticket already opened
so I closed it you could see that this
is the frame we have set it at x equal
to 0 and y equal to 400 so it would
measure
as y equal to 0 here and y equal to 400
here
so we have placed the frame now we'll
place the buttons on that
and first we will set
a logo for simply music player
that we have
enough folder
so this is the logo for our simply music
player we will set it
put that will write the command
first we will create a variable and name
it as image icon
and here we will use photo image
so
like after writing in this photo image
it would like it would create a photo
image object and you can use it
in other widgets that accept an image
argument that is some buttons they
accept image argument photo image
argument
you can use the images there also and
the image object is returned by the
photo image function
it's the easy to display a picture in
Python however the photo image class
only supports the GIF and PGM PPM
formats which is a concern jpeg jpg and
PNG are the formats that are most often
used
so now
in the photo image object we will just
write the location of the file
as we have it in the same folder so we
will write the name only that is logo
space PNG
and the extension that is PNG only
now
to get it set as icon photo we'll write
the command root dot icon photo
and
past argument as false comma
image underscore icon
now we'll save the file
first we'll close the previous one
and run it
you could see that
the logo has been placed there
so
now moving on
we will create the menu
we will again run the file
so here we will create the menu to
browser music
for that first
you will create a variable menu
and create a photo image object
and
write the file name only as here we
don't have to set the part as all the
images are in the same folder only
so for this we will use the menu.png
that is the white inch I will show you
what you will get as output
to
we have to place this in inverted commas
and now for this we will create a label
so in Tinker in dig into some widgets
can display an image such as label and
button
is a widget that is used to implement
display boxes where you can place text
or images
so we will create a label here
and paste the manual.png image on that
so to create it we'll write the command
we have started with label and inside we
will pass root
and the image
we will write the variable name here
that is menu
and now we will place it
will position it in our take enter
window
so for that write the command please
and inside
write x equal to zero
and
the dimensions
okay
so y would be
580
and would also set the width and height
for that
and the width would be 485 so it could
cover
the whole
sorry I didn't try to wait
it would be 485 and now we will set the
height
I will set as 100 only guys
it would be
in the bottom section
so
you don't get much height so we'll save
this
and run the file
you can see that we have created a label
here also and a label here also and we
have pasted the white image place the
white image on that level
so this is the label that is of the
white color and now we have placed
another image on
another label
so I will show you what
purpose we have done that
so first we will create a button
that would be for the browse music
now it will write
first pass root and
then what text we want to show on that
button
that would be
browse music
and then we will set the width of that
button
that would be 59
and then
would set its height
and
set the height as 1 only
and now you you can set
phone tool so like which font you want
to get displayed on that button
for that
you just have to write want
equal to
and start the circular brackets
and inside you can write
which font you want I will go with
calibri
and font size would be 12.
and I want it bold
so in inverted commands I will write
vault
and outside this circular bracket
I will set the foreground color
that is the text color only foreground
color
s black
you can write the hexa code we just
write the name of the color
and we will set the background color as
white for this button
use hexapod here
that is 60 Maps
and now
what function does this button do
so it will show us the music that
would be stored in our folder
we will browse the folder and it will
show us the mp3 mp3 files that would be
contained in that folder
so in command we would write the name of
the function that we will create to get
all the MP3 files
so we will
finish and we're also calling
now outside this bracket
we'll place it
showing error as we have not
to find the add music function so we'll
place it
at x equal to zero
y
equal to 550.
no
and scroll bar
so that when we get Ola MP3 files we can
just browse just by scrolling
so we can get all the MP3 files on that
small window we will create now
so we'll set the scroll bar for that
for that write the command
scroll bar
and inside
get off
play music
so first
will
set another frame
and we will
get it as
gray color only with that
we will write the command
frame underscore music
we will create a frame
and inside will pass root
and set the Border equal to 2
and
relief
equal to Rich
so we have set the relief equal to Rich
so relief is a style and it's a style of
a widget that refers to certain
simulated 3D effects and we are giving
the 3D fact to a button and that effect
is Ridge
so we will see that but before that we
have two
get our add music defined
showing a soup
no you won't get the taken term window
as we have to
Define the
and music
so we have created the frame and now we
will place this
and after that we will
create that music
function
for this we will write
name underscore music
that
moves the variable name and
period place
and now we will position it in a tick
enter window
so we want it at x equal to zero
equal to
so we would place it at
585
and we'll so Define its width and height
so width would be 485
and height
is
100
yeah so we were creating the scroll bar
so first we'll create the scroll bar and
then Define the add music function
so now we will set the scroll bar in the
frame music
variable as you want the scroll bar in
that frame
I will show you in the demo only after I
create tired music function
so first we'll create that music
function only
so we will create it here
and music
going to first you want that it should
have path and here we would use
file dialog
so it would pop out the dialog box
to the directory way which we would
assign or take it to
next
foreign
change
directory
pass the path here
Source equal to
let's Dot
list of directory
path
okay
foreign
so first if the path we have chosen
and here we will change the path and in
this songs variable
we'll get the list of all the songs
in that directory
and now
we will
create or run a for Loop
or song in songs
but all the songs we got
f
Ong ends with
MP3
that is 2 MP3
foreign
[Music]
so we will
get this playlist variable working in
another function that would be the play
music function
so it should play the music for that
will
create the function
play
music
create a variable name
that would be music underscore name and
inside
playlist Dot get and make it active
and now
we will
print
music name
and this would be printed in the
terminal
first
active that is which music is playing
and now you want to use the mixer class
and music Dot load
function and pass the playlist
the function node get and get it as
diff
and now
here we will
update
now we are getting errors for playlist
so first
create the playlist variable that would
be
having all the songs in that
so with that would look right
a variable playlist
and that would be equal to
it would have the list box
equal to
list box
and inside we'll pass the
name that we have created for music
and set its width
that would be equal to 100
and now we will set the font for that
so
you can see all the names of the MP3
files in the same font only
and for
that would write
Times New Roman
and set the font sizes
10.
and outside this bracket
will set the background color for the
playlist
called that right PG
and we'll set it as gray only
so
I have support for degree is
3333
and that is six times
we'll close the inverted commas
and set the foreground color
as gray only
now
a select background
that would be of the light blue color
set the cursor
and send to I will explain you
what this means
first we'll set the Border
equal to 0 only
Vice scroll command
that would be equal to
light blue
now we will set the
wire scroll command
that would be equal to scroll dot set
so it should be used to scroll
so we have set the cursor equal to N2
that means that it would convert to hand
when we scroll on the list box
that is when we would try to select any
of the MP3 player files it would show us
the hand cursor
and
the background color is light blue we
have set and scroll command equal to
scroll load set
okay now we will configure it
okay
let me have some errors we will resolve
them and we will see the output also
just after this
so first we will configure the scroll
bar
so that will use variable only scroll
load config
and inside
we will
have the command
equal to playlist
Dot
to buy View
so we should have in the y-axis only
and now
go back the scroll bar
paste it and right
and fill the y axis
for that will write fill
equal to y
and now
we will
pack the playlist
playlist dot pack
and paste it
decide equal to right
and it should
build
both the sides
I think it should be filled
so that will write the command
which I cannot appear after keyword
arguments
okay we'll get it sorted
save the file
run it
so you can see that
we have the browse music button here and
if we click it we have the functioning
it will
select the folder
create MP3 player and this is the folder
that is music and we'll select it it has
four files
I'll show you in that also so this is
the folder it has four files
it is displaying us all the four files
and you can see that we have the cursor
as hand here that is we have set it as
hand to
so now
we will do other functionings that is
place the JF run it and place the
buttons so first we will place the
buttons
and run it
so for that
after this Frame music will start with
the buttons
so first we'll create the play button
for that we will create a variable and
name it as button play
and we will use a photo
a picture
for that button that will create a photo
image object
and pass the file for it
and we have that file name play1.png
so we'll just write the name of that
file in inverted commas
and now
we will
set the functioning
set the pattern will pass
root
and the image
is equal to
the variable we have set it for that
that is
button
play
okay
skeptical play
and
will set the background color for the
button
that would be white only because we have
the white label here
so it would
be perfect for that and I will set the
Border
that would be equal to zero
and
okay we have to place it inverted commas
else it would be
functioning as a comment Only We have
set the border that is equal to zero now
height
okay
h a g h t
oh so just for both the spanning of
height
okay so I have to declare the height
first
so we will
get these buttons in 16 to 60 Dimensions
only we'll set the height as 60 and
width
also S60
and now we would set the command for
this button so what functioning should
it do
for that
we will write the function name
that is play music
and
now we will place this
at x equal to
215
and y equal to
487.
and we have created the play music
function above
you can see that
it has the functioning to play the music
we have used the mixer.music.lord
from the pi game
and it would get the playlist and the
active contents there and it would play
it
so we are done with a play button
we'll save it and run the file
I'm going to take into window is opened
first of all goes right
started
first we'll browse so this was the
folder getting music let's select this
folder you can see we have these four
files we'll click on the one and just
click on the play button
okay uh we forgot to add one functioning
so first
we will
create all these buttons and then add
all other functionings
now we will create the second button
that would be the stop button
put that
you will create a variable and name it
as button stop
and here also we'll create a photo image
object
dude
pass file and inverted commas
we have stop1.png for this
so we'll just write the file name
and in the next line we will Define the
functioning of this button
so inside button will pass root
and image
that is the variable
button stop
and set the background color
equal to White only
and that would be in the inverted commas
and now we'll set its border
that would be zero
and height and width would be 60 only
and after that we will set its command
that would be
mixer Dot
music
dot stop so we are using the mixer
cast the music class inside that and the
stop function
and now we will place this
window with that we'll write the
dimensions for that x equal to 130
and y equal to 487
so we have created the stop button
we will save this and run the file
you can see that the stop button is
also displaying on a ticket window
and now
we will make our third button
that would be the pause button
for that we'll use the post one PNG this
is the image
so for that
you can just
copy these things
place it here
so button
pause equal to photo image and we will
use the image
pose one dot PNG
and
get it
as we have set all others as big
so button pause background color white
water zero right 60 with 60 command it
would be mixer dot music dot pose
and we'll place it at
300 comma 487
we'll save this file
and run it
you can see that we have the pause
button
displayed here
now
we will
get the volume button Note the volume
button just as image
so this is the image volume.png
we will
get it though
so for that we will create a variable
volume one
and create a photo
image object
and set the file location
and the location is
already placed in the same folder so
we'll just write the name of the file
that is volume.png
and that would be in the inverted commas
and now
we will place this
at
x equal to 20. and
y equal to 487
now we'll save this
and run the file
so we are having some errors
okay
we contactly use the place here
first
create another variable and create a
label for this image
so for that
to reduce panel
and equal to
well
sign will pass root comma
that is equal to
volume one
and now
we will use the place
and place it at
x equal to
it was and
300 and
why would peace
that would be 487.
so now we'll save this file and run it
you can see
okay
we have made a mistake here
so
it should be here so X would be less it
would be around 20 and Y would be same
for that only
so we'll change that
save this
and run the file again
yeah you can see that we have the volume
image
we have the play button the post button
and the stop button so we'll get the job
working for us
and now we will
get our GF working but before that we
will
make the mixer initialize so that uh
buttons they should function that is
play pause and stop
so we've imported the mixer class so we
will initialize it
and save this
and run the file
now you can browse the music
click on the any MP3 file and
click on the play button
you can hear that the music is playing
so I will pause it
and now we will start with the
functioning of our gif
so we have to cut the previous part
and now
start with frame count
so the frame count of rjf is 30 and we
will store it in a variable
and now we'll create another variable
as frames and inside
start with
square brackets and create a photo image
object
and inside will pass the file
the GI file
the name of the file is A1 dot JF
and here we have to specify the format
of the file
put that you write format
equal to
in
commas
chair
and
index
and we'll set the index
and
I
assume we would be using the list
comprehension here
no we will run the loop
so for that right for
I
in
and use the range
of the frame count
so what we will do is
the GIF has so many images in that so we
have to run a loop so it would again
repeat itself
as the frame count would be equal to the
count as the images would be repeated in
a loop we will set the count equal to 0
and repeat it again
so for that
now we'll create a function
and name it as update
inside will pass a variable Randy
create a variable with name frame and
inside
we will pass
IND variable
names
and as
this image would be displayed
we will increment
the IND variable
and if
IND
is equal to equal to frame count that is
if it has displayed all the images in
the gif
we will set it at zero and run it again
and would set the jfn label so
we will configure it
and we have to find the label also
so for that
right label
equal to
label inside will pass the root
and now we'll configure it
and pass image
equal to what
frame we have
currently click
and now
we will use the after function
and pass 40 milliseconds so that
the animation would start again
and pass the update function
the current IND
and now we will place the label
and x equal to 0 and y equal to zero
and again we will run the after function
and pass zero milliseconds and the
update function
zero frames
okay
let's find this
if statement only
okay
first we have to
place the label statement about no
now
we are done with a gif
save this
and then the file
so we are getting an error here
okay
so
subtitude
okay then save this file and run it
again
okay
encode displayed
so we have this label above
just browse the files select the folder
and click on any file and just click on
the play button you can see that our MP3
player is working
we'll just set the UI again
you close it
or you could stop it
so we will
get this
the other words
let's try to go up the buttons
now we'll save the file
and click on run button
you can see that the GIF has taken the
whole frame
and now browse the files
and selected the folder and our if
statement will find the MPG files and
click on the file
I'm just going to play buttons
[Music]
you can see that our simply music player
is working fine
so I will share the code link with you
in the description
then we will create a video player using
python before starting let us have a
simple question to brush up on a
knowledge
and your question is which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file and your options are
first option is dot python
the second is dot py third is dot PL and
the fourth one is dot PJ
please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the print comment you can
pause the video give it a thought and
answer in the comment section
and insightful for you guys if you have
focused on building strong fundamental
skills for career growth in that case
you can check out a free course to Learn
Python Basics with a completion
certificate from scale up by simply love
you can check the python Basics free
scale up course with that link in the
description box below
and now moving on we'll start with a
project that is creating a video player
using python
so for that
first we will create a folder
and name it as
create
to video player
using python
and
inside will open the command prompt
and type the command code space period
and press enter it will open our Visual
Studio code as I would be coding in the
visual studio code only you can code in
any ideally
that you are suitable with
so moving on first I will create a file
with the name video
now to start with our project first we
need to install the python modules we
don't have to write new code for
everything
we can use existing code written by
experts that are in the form of modules
so first we will install the modules
and the modules will require here would
be the first one would be tick enter and
take enter is a python module that is
used to develop GUI that is graphical
user interface and there's no need to
install any module for that
as the take into module is a part of the
standard python Library so it's already
installed if you have installed the
python
so you don't have to install the take
enter
we will also use date time module here
so for that we'll write the command okay
space install
it
time and press enter
as you can see that it states that the
requirement is already satisfied I've
already installed the date time module
so I don't have to install that you can
just write the command pip space
installed space date time and you can
easily install the date time module
I am moving on uh we will also install
another module that would be TK video
player for that we will write the
command tip space
installed
TK
video player
and press enter
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied as I have already
installed the module so I don't have to
install it again
you can just write the command or you
can search
in the browser right take a video player
installation it will be directed to the
TK video player official page there you
will find the command to install the
module
so moving on
we will start
building our video player
so for that first we'll import the
packages
so first we'll import
all the classes from taken to
next
we will import
date time
to imported the date time module
now we will import
T into s t k
we have made an allies for this so we
will use TK only
so now we will import the field dialog
box so that we can open the files that
we want to browse and play on our video
player
so for that we will import
from take into
import
field
look
now we'll import take a video player
that would be taken to video class from
take a video player module
so for that we will write from
take into video
foreign
[Music]
so for that we'll write a command
that would be the root
equal to
the Allies name that was TK
Dot
TK
so this is the simple command
that would create a root window and it
would display it on the screen
so for that we'll write root Dot
main Loop
we will save this program
and run it
you could say that that take enter
window has appeared on the screen so
this is a taken top window
so in this window only we'll create a
video player
so we'll start with that process
now uh as you've seen the taken down
window
I will show you again
so we will give it a title as we have
written TK here it's default that TK
would be here as we have made the last
name as TK only
so we will change it and we will write
as simply video play
so of course that will write the command
route to Titan and inside
we will write what we want to name the
dig into window
we will name it as simply
video
so tinginter provides many methods and
one of them is geometry
this method would be used to set the
dimensions of the tick enter window as
you have seen it has appeared in the
small manner so we will set its
dimensions
and it would also use to set the
position of the main window of the
user's desktop so for that we'll write
the command
root dot geometry
and inside we will set the x-axis as
800.
x and y axis
with pixel 700
and
from above it would be 290 that would be
the x axis it would be 290 pixels down
I'll show you like what it would be
and y axis it would be
10 so we would save this
and then the program so you can see that
we have set the x-axis is 800 y-axis as
700 and 290 pixels that was x axis we
have shifted it from 0
to here that is 290 and 10 from above
that is on the y axis
and we can see that it has changed the
name that is it's now simply video
player
so we have changed the title of our
ticket window
so moving on
now we'll create a frame
so for that
we will write the command frame equal to
TK that was the Allies for the decanter
Dot
frame
inside we will pass root
and we will just
pack it
so fourth frame if you don't know I will
just tell you about the frame now frame
is a rectangular region on the screen
and it can also be used as a foundation
class to implement complex widgets it is
used to organize a group of widgets so
if we want to organize any button or any
image so you can just create a frame and
organize those widgets into the frame
and we have used the pack here so the
pack geometry manager packs widgets
relative to the earlier widget tick
enter literally packs all the widgets
one after the other in the window we can
use options like fill expand and site to
control this geometry manager that is
back
so we will be seeing that back and we'll
use it many times so you will see the
functioning of that also
so now
we'll save it and run it
so now we will place an icon here for
simply video player we want to place
an icon so for that
we have created an icon
you can create your own
I have stored it in this logo PNG and
these images
we would be using
in a project only
that would be for the for the
forwarding and backwarding of the video
so we'll paste all these pictures here
and now
we will place the logo.png
logo PNG file
that is we have created the icon for our
simply video player so we'll place this
on the top and for that we'll write the
command
so for that you will write
image underscore icon
we will create a variable
and that would be equal to we'll create
a photo image object
I will tell you about it
and here we'll write the location
of the file we want to place it as the
icon photo
foreign
so this is the function here icon photo
and in this
we will pass Folds
comma image icon
that is in which we have stored our logo
and now we'll save this
and
run it
so first we have to close up previous
tick into window
so I will close it and
it will run a program
and you can see that we have placed the
logo for simply video player
so
I will tell you about the photo image
object first
and we have used the icon photo
method
and that is used to set the title bar
icon of any tick enter window
but to set any images the icon of Title
One image should be the object of photo
image object we have created the photo
image object so what this photo image
object is about
so when we just use the photo image and
pass the file location in that it would
create a photo image object
so you can use it in any widget after
you create the photo image object
and you can pass it as any argument as
image argument in any widget
and the image object is written by the
photo image function it's easy to
display a picture in Python however the
photo image class only supports the GIF
and PPM formats which is a concern
and JPEG and jpg and PNG are the formats
that are most often used
and we are using the PNG so there's no
any problem to use that
so moving on
we will create a frame in a tick enter
window
oh that will write the command
lower underscore frame
and that would be equal to TK that was
the last name we are using for tick into
or period frame
and inside here we will pass root
and we'll set the background color
as white
and we will write the hexa code for the
color white here and that is
6 times f
and
now we will use the back function here
we will place this Frame
put that you will
use the variable we have created
and the pack widget
okay uh we have to place it in the
periods and it will show error
else it would be treated as a comment
only as we have used the hashtag and we
didn't place it in inverted compass
so now we will pack it and inside we'll
use the properties as fill equal to both
so it would be fitted in the whole
window
and we will
place this at the bottom of the taken
turn window
so for that we'll write send equal to
bottom and moving on
now we will create the patterns and
before creating the buttons first we
should save the demonstration of what we
are going to make
so for that I will take you to a code
and that stress we will
run a program and you can see this is
the ticket window and this is the simply
video player we have paste icon there
and we have to add other functions that
would be the browse
and then we will place other buttons
that would be play pose
forward backward and the slider
so that you can reach to any duration
you want to see on the video you would
be paying so we'll close it
as we have
click on the previous button it has yeah
it has given an error
so we will run it again
so when we click on browse it would
direct us to any path you want
to play one of our own videos that would
be MP3 player using python
and then we'll click on play you can see
that our video is playing
so this is the demonstration of what we
are gonna make
no
we will start with placing our buttons
and after that we will add the
functioning to them
so
we will create the browse button first
for that we will
create a variable load button that would
be equal to
okay
load button
and shine as the root
and we'll set the text
equal to browse
and set the background color
for button and that would be white only
one two three four five six
hexagon for white
and we will also set the font
for the browse button
and we have to place this hexa code in
inverted commas
else it would be termed as the comment
only
it will be starting with a hash so we
have to place it in inverted commas and
now we will set the font
for
browse button
and that would be
we'll set it as calibri
and we'll also set the font size
so first we'll set it as Calgary
and set the font size as 12.
and we will also make it bold
which we have to place it
round brackets
yeah
and now we will
make a command for this button so what
does this function
what function will this will this button
do
so for that we'll
write command equal to and we will
name our function as plot video only
we will create this function
and and the functioning to browse the
MP4 files
now
we'll back this button
with that we'll write the command
two button into it
tag
and inside we will use
padding
in X direction that would be 12.
and padding
wired action we'll set it as four
and anchor anchor is where you want to
place the button
so I will place it in the North West
that is in the
upper left Direction
so for that we'll write the command TK
Dot and W Northwest
anchor is the positioning of the button
angle equal to TK Dot
Northwest sorry
so we have added the
padding X and Y
moving on we will
create the
click into video
download the window in which our video
would be playing for that
first we'll create a variable
video underscore player and that would
be equal to
T into video it would be using that
function
and inside we will pass root
scaled equal to
so you can visit that take into a video
official page and you can see these
functions there
you would easily understand like why
they are working and what's the
functioning
and now we'll pack this window
suppose that we will use the variable
and pack it
we will expand the window
and ask it
to fill in both the directions
I will show you all the functioning as
we will create all the buttons
and then we will
create the functions for them
so what command we would be placing in
these buttons after that
you would be able to see
heading into window
so now we will do be making the backward
button
so for that
do a greater variable
and name it as button backward
and here we will use a photo
make a picture
in this picture
you could
eat that
clearly
the folder we have paste so this is the
backboard image we will use this on the
button
so for that we will create the photo
image object
inside the photo image object we will
place the location of the file
as it's already located in the same
folder so we'll just write the name of
the file that is backward dot PNG
okay
and
actually it's showing an uh we have to
place it in inverted commas
now
we will create another variable
aiming as back and inside
we will create the button
EK Dot
button
and inside
will pass lower frame as you will place
all these buttons on the lower frame we
have created
so lower frame
comma and here we will pass the image
and in image will pass the variable in
which we have created the photo image
object and so the name of the variable
is button backward
and now we will set this border
at 0 and height
equal to 50 and width also equal to 50.
and now we'll
ask this to ask this to function and for
that we'll use the
command and inside
will use Lambda
and we'll create a function with the
name skip
and we'll skip five seconds
the back widget to pack this button
we will place it in this side
that would be left
so it will be defining the function skip
in the meantime
before we will
make another button that would be the
forward button
and the play post Button as we have seen
in the demonstration so first we'll
create the play post button
put that we will
create a variable
inside will pass North frame
and here we will name
text that would be displaying code
button
that would be play and we have to place
it in inverted commas
and we'll set the width for this button
that would be 40.
and we'll also set its height
that would be equal to 2
every sufficient
and now
we will
add the functioning to it we will
declare
play post button very limited play pause
on it
as it will be functioning play and pause
now we will pack this button
so that will use the variable name
that is play post button
foreign
and inside
we will expand this button as you've
seen in the demonstration to expand it
we will use
expand equal to true
[Music]
equal to both sides
okay and we'll place it
and site
so
and side equal to left
now we will create the
forward button so for that we will
create a variable
as button forward
and inside we'll create the photo image
object
and inside will pass the file location
as we have already located the file in
the same folder so we'll just name it
will write the name of the file that is
forward dot PNG
you can see in the folder that it's
forward
we'll use this image
now we have created the photo image
object and now
we built create the button for that we
will
write the command
create variable and name it is play
button
create a button with hit the quantity
button and inside
this would be placed on the North frame
only
and
image
port
and the variable
button
forward
so now we would set its border equal to
zero
ID equal to 50
and with
equal to 50.
and we'll also Define its command
that would be equal to we'll use Lambda
and inside here we will
be forwarding the video for five seconds
it would peel Lambda
and now we'll name the function as skip
we'll create a single function and if we
pass plus 5 it would be forwarding a
video with 5 Seconds
and we pass minus 5 it would be
backwarding the video with five seconds
now we will use the pack widget
to place this button
and declare
side is left
yeah
so now we have created the buttons
now moving on
we will Define some functions now
we'll start with
these are the buttons
now I'll Define some functions
so we'll start with the duration
to update the duration both that will
name the function as
update underscore duration
and inside will pass the event
an event that we would be clicking
on the slide bar
so for that
first we will create a variable duration
and inside
we would be using the video info
entered
inside the square brackets
you will pass the duration
now the end time
we will create a variable
so
with the name end time
and
pass
text in that
and that would be equal to
string
we'll use the date time module here
and time Delta
and inside
seconds would be equal to duration
so time Delta it's a duration of time
that is used for manipulating time only
so
and now
you will
create on the slider
for that
you will create a variable
progress underscore slider
and inside the square brackets
pass the duration that is
to which time
we would be directing it to
and
after that we will create another
function
and name it as update scale
that would be the scale of the
slide bar
so we'll name the function as update
underscore scale and we'll pass the
event in that
and
now
we will use progress underscore value
variable and
set it
and pass the variable
ID and scripture
that we have created for video tab
that would be the current duration
so it would fetch the current duration
we will be updating the scale with the
current duration
for that we have used the configuration
method and
we will find another function
that would be the load video
and we have base a command also for the
load video
so this function would be adding the
functionality to the browse button
put that
we will create a variable a name that's
file path and use the file dialog class
and
the function ask open file name
and inside if
file under score
but
and if a video player
it's loading the file path
so to progress slider
foreign
duration
and the form duration would also be
equal to zero
we will declare the progress later
so do not worry
and now
and the functioning
I know
some functionality
scientists only so we will set the
button as play as you have seen that our
button would be displaying two options
that would be play in the pose and if we
open the file
so it would set the slider to zero only
and the button to the play for that we
will write
play underscore pause underscore button
that is the variable of the play post
button
and inside would pass the text
in the square brackets
that would be play
when we would be choosing any mp4 file
so we would be setting the button as
play
progress underscore
value
note set
to pass zero
now we'll create another function
and name it as seek
and inside would pass the value
and we need to
this function would be using
to seek a specific time frame
with that
will
use the function seek
and pass the integer value in that
and
now we will declare the skip function
that will be adding the command to both
our buttons that would be the forward
button and the backward button and
inside will pass
value in the form of integer
so this would be used to skip the
setting a second sorry
so here
we would be calling our C function and
inside
will pass integer
progress
slide
one duration we want
to put get function
the value
you want to make it forward so we'll
just declare the progress slider
variable so don't worry we'll sort it
out
you would see that we have used the seek
function here and we'll also use the
set function
I will use some set function that is
already defined we don't have to create
and so
for that I will write the command
progress underscore value
dot set
and inside we will pass
progress
underscore slider
you can use the get function
foreign
we will
declare the
play post function
so it would be used to play and pause
the video
so we will use Intel statement here if
foreign
defining this function first we will
create the variable that is
video player
and here we will use the tick enter
window module
side will pass root
it's scaled
equal to true
and now we will use the variable
and pack it
spank this
is equal to true
both sides
and T would be capital for two
so before creating this function first
we'll create the variables so that we
don't get confused so we'll start with
start time start underscore
time and that would be equal to
TK
we'll create a label
and inside you will pass root
and text equal to
ring inside would pass
date time
Android
time Delta
and it's set
seconds
equal to zero
and now we will use the pack widget for
this
so start underscore time
put back
and we will
Place its side
as left
and now we will create
another variable that is progress
transfer value
that is equal to TK
Dot
where and we'll pass root into it
and now we will create the variable to
press slider
and that would be we will create a scale
here
inside will pass the root
will pass the variable
that would be the progress value as it
keeps on changing
and we will start this scale from
0
and
2
0 so in starting it would be in the
initial Point only for the from n0
scale
from N2 equal to 0 okay now we will set
its orientation
it's horizontal
and we will set its command
equal to seek
we have defined the C function
so now
this would be easy for you guys to
understand it
now we'll pack this progress slider
and set its side equal to
left
and it should
fill the
expected width
so for that we'll write will equal to
X
and expand
equal to true
so we have created the variable start
time progress value progress slider so
we are left with end time
and
this will create a label
pass root into that
text
equal to
we'll convert it into string that would
be date time
Dot
time Delta
and inside will pass
seconds
that would be equal to zero
and now we'll use the back configure
a configure widget
to packet
so
back
and side equal to
left
so set
video player
we will use the bind function
and inside
will pass duration
okay we have defined it here
to create this we need
the video player
variable
oh
you will
update the duration here
so first update duration
and if
we need to go clear
we'll do it bind
and if it's second changed
so I will update this scale here
and if video player
load point
ended
so what will pass the video ended
function
not created the video ended function so
we will create that
compare the update duration update scale
the video ended
so we are left with Video Edit function
and the Playboys function
so we will complete that first
so if
video player
is post
foreign
[Music]
video player
to play then click on the player post
button
and now we'll set its text
to underscore
pause
underscore
button and inside the square
brackets
will pass the
text
and that would be equal to
if the video player is paused
so we'll play it and set the button text
as pause
and
else
video player
is
else if the video player is playing we
will
make a test pose
we'll use the pose function there
and set the text
and the score
button
for the text will use the square
brackets
and set it as
a
so we are done with the play pose
function now we are left with
the video ended function
so
that
create the function and pass the event
through it
so it would handle the video when the
video would be ended
okay so we have to
press above
foreign
[Music]
first we will complete a
function
so
for that
use progress slider
and set it as
progress underscore slide
right now
and pass the two
that duration at which it would be in it
and set the play post button text
pass this in square brackets
let's play
as the video would be completed so we
would
turn this back into the plane
and we'll set the progress
slider
set
at zero
so now let's see what is you getting
so we are designed with errors
so I'll save the file and click on play
button
so we have got some error
in 966 and equal to India
okay
and then again
you can browse but they're not showing
so let's save this and run until
actually close to previous window and
run it again
okay so we are getting our browse button
downwards
okay
based on video player between as
these are
in the packings only so first we will
place our browse button then the video
player then the backboard button then
the post button
and then the forward button
and we have named it as play
let's save this
and run it
try and close the keyboard stick enter
window
now you can see that the browse button
has
automated's position so we'll click on
the browse button
let's open in the downloads and there is
MP3 player using python only
click on the play button
the file is playing click on the pause
button
and you can
see the functioning of forward and
backward
buttons
so
we are done with our project if you have
any doubt you could just
ping in the comment section and with
that we have come to the end of this
session
and I have something for you guys
just wait
so if you are aiming to get certified in
Python Programming course
and you want to build up python software
development career in that case you can
check this python certificate course by
simply now which will open the doors for
the best career options and
opportunities to find the details of
this python certification course you can
check in the link in the description box
below
it would be the ideal solution to help
you build your career in the right
direction and I hope this session was
interesting and informative if you liked
it please let us know in the comment
section below and also do subscribe to
our Channel and stay tuned for More
Foods
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here